hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar the
expanding role of diagnostic
next generation sequencing in the
clinical microbiology laboratory
i am jennifer woods of lab roots and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots
and brought to you by microgen
diagnostics to learn more
visit microgendx.com
let's get started before we begin i'd
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions
as you would like at any time you want
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
at the end of the presentation if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box located on the
far
left of your screen i now present
today's speakers
dr joseph f john low country infectious
diseases and affiliate professor of
medicine
medical university of south carolina and
dr
michael g schmidt professor department
of microbiology
and immunology medical university of
south carolina
for a complete biography on our speakers
please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen dr john and dr
schmidt you may now begin your
presentations
good morning i'm dr joseph john and i'd
like to welcome you to this webinar
on next generation sequencing and the
clinical microbiologist
i'd like to thank microgen diagnostics
for sponsoring the program
here to discuss the basic technology of
this revolutionary
activity is dr michael schmidt
dr schmidt is a professor of
microbiology and immunology
at the medical university of south
carolina in charleston south carolina
dr schmidt has had an illustrious career
as a basic and applied microbiologist
many of you may know him best for his
bi-weekly podcast
this week in microbiology sponsored by
the american society for microbiology
so without further ado i'd like to turn
this over to dr schmidt
thank you dr john and welcome everyone
to today's
webinar first up uh we're going to
get through the normal rigors of a
scientific presentation
namely the disclosures and both dr john
and i
are members of the scientific advisory
board for microgen
and again the opinions are those of the
authors
and not necessarily those of our
employers
the learning objectives for today's
presentation
are pretty much straightforward and we
hope that each of the objectives
is met and that they give you something
that you can use
in your clinical practice or in
helping the clinicians make appropriate
decisions
there are three that we're going to
cover first the limitations
inherent to traditional microbiological
cultures
and why next-gen sequencing may
offer you an opportunity to help in your
diagnostic matrix
secondly how clinical specimens
evaluated
by next-gen sequencing techniques can
aid in making
clinical decisions and finally how you
can practically evaluate
information from the next-gen sequencing
reports
that are provided from you from our
sponsor microgen dx
in order to assist you in your decision
matrix
for the care of patients so we're going
to start with a problem
many of us and the clinical microbiology
world have seen this
often and those who are treating
patients
struggle with this this is the case of a
sterile pieria
with persistent urinary white blood
cells but
negative standard urine cultures the
patient is literally presenting
with the symptoms of an infection but as
best we try the clinical laboratory is
unable to reveal the culprit
microbe i'm going to hopefully convince
you today
of the value afforded by that coincident
culture
as well as next-gen sequencing in order
to aid you in understanding the
microorganisms that are
present in a particular specimen
so the challenges and limitations of
culture are many
many of you are well familiar with them
and i have just
selected a few in order to highlight
one of the first that i run to call your
attention to
is less than one percent of the known
microbes will grow
in traditional culture methodologies
that we routinely use
in the clinical laboratory anaerobes as
you well know
are extremely difficult to grow and
often are inhibited
unless you're specifically caring for
them whether or not you're using
anaerobic transport medium whether or
not you have the
appropriate facility in order to culture
anaerobes
and one of the other aspects is if the
patient
is coincidentally infected with a fungus
the fungi can take over 20 days
to generate a result and oftentimes they
require
special media this makes it very
challenging
for the clinician the clinical
limitations with culture are just going
to sum up
less than one percent of the microbes
identified can routinely be grown
in a clinical laboratory and what we
know from the literature
for one particular recalcitrant type
infection
that is periprosthetic joint infections
in up to 50 percent of those
infection cages cultures fail to isolate
the infecting microbe and oftentimes
we now know from the literature that
those infections
are often poly polymicrobial and as a
consequence
of a biofilm-based infection
the clinical end result of course is
negative cultures have been associated
with about a four and a half fold
increase in a risk
of re-infection when compared to a
culture
positive test so consequently this
impacts
on how well the patient will respond
to your treatment course and again as i
mentioned just previously
many of these infections are poly
microbial that in fact
influence your choice of antimicrobials
that you may
be wishing to treat the patient with
enter the persisters and viable but
non-culturable cells
these are variants for normal cells that
are tolerant
to antibiotics and are responsible
oftentimes for the recalcitrants
that we see in our patients towards the
treatment
with common antimicrobials much of this
work
in the field has been pioneered by dr
kim lewis
who is a university distinguished
professor at northeastern
university's college of science and
approximately
0.3 of the microbial community
responsible for an infection may be
in point of fact for sister cells to
give you an idea or
back of the envelope calculation if you
have a density of about a billion
organisms per ml approximately
three million of those microbes are in a
persistent state
what this means that the cells are
refractory to antimicrobials
and as the antimicrobial is diluted out
of the patient
these microbes can revert and grow
and we know three million organisms are
a significant
presence and they do indeed cause
problems
i've placed on this particular slide two
references
that you might find useful we have
transitioned our thinking about the
importance of persister cells into this
next concept
of viable but non-culturable in how
they can be perceived as persistent
cells
they effectively are a consequence of
stressors
that are applied to the microbial
community
and this concept of viable but
non-culturable or more
frequently abbreviated in the literature
as bbnc
was pioneered about 40 years ago by rita
caldwell's group
in describing this observation in vibrio
cholera
we now appreciate that any environmental
stressor
could send a community into this
culturable but
still virulent state and in a seminal
paper
published by professor bill keeble
from the university of southampton in
the united kingdom
kevil and colleagues actually describe
how
viable but non-culturable cultivars of
listeria monocytogenes
and salmonella enterica sierra var
thompson
are actually induced into this bbnc
state simply by being exposed to a very
low concentration
of sodium hypochlorite principally in
the realm of 3
to 100 parts per million to give you a
frame of reference this
is often the concentration
of bleach that is routinely added to the
wash water
that are ready to eat produce is so
often washed with
and sent for us to consume so this
concentration
of the strong oxidant hypochlorite can
send the microbe into this vbnc state
but remember that strong
oxidants are a routine of our natural
immune process that our systems
use to rid us of microbes so
the stressors of our immune response
may actually send part of the community
into this vb and c state
so let's take it back to the clinic the
consequence
of vbnc to the clinician and to
laboratory stewardship now these chronic
symptoms of an
infection would seemingly know known
cause
really drive the provider crazy because
the patient
is demanding to know when they will get
better
they are prescribing antimicrobials
which of course
impact on your anti-microbial
stewardship budget
and the microbe is probably just
ignoring
the drug that you are providing to the
patient
secondly this sterile pile area with
this
persistent urinary white blood cells are
actually indicative that the patient
is still having an infectious response
but the standard negative urine cultures
are suggestive of something more complex
such as tuberculosis or whether or not
it may be a vb and c state that has been
induced
by the antimicrobial or in point of fact
the patient's
own immune response so the fundamental
question before the clinician
and the clinical laboratorian is when
or do you even re-culture
so now here's where i sort of try to
transition into
offering you the value proposition
afforded
by culture in ngs testing
one of the first questions that you need
to ask yourselves
is if you're going to send this out or
if you're going to do this
internally is can you do it what types
of specimens
is your laboratory proficient in
remember
the types of specimen are as varied as
the number of
infections so again you have to ask the
question can the lab
do it secondly are they proficient
microgen dx has been
validated by the college of american
pathology
over these past many years and have they
have been
submitting over a thousand blinded
specimens
and they have a mean accuracy rate in
determining the identity of the unknown
at approximately 99.2 percent
the third question you need to consider
is
how fast will you get the results
back whether it be from
pcr if you happen to be doing that
internally
whether it be a full ngs workup that
you're sending
off site how quickly can you get those
answers back
and finally this third concept of the
resistome
these are the antimicrobials that are
resident
in the community recall that many of
these recalcitrant
infections can be polymicrobial
so the microbes may actually have
a resistance profile or the community
to many antimicrobials so the resistom
is effectively asking
what antibiotic resistance traits that
have clinical relevance are present
in the scent patient's specimen and
finally
there's the stewardship issues both
laboratory
and antimicrobially from the laboratory
perspective
uh the cost for the microgen approach
is less than 300 dollars per specimen
this will of course lead to better
outcomes if you
identify who's there and you develop a
treatment profile
and as well is by identifying the
organism
early you'll have a better handle on
what antimicrobial to prescribe
which in turn will affect your
antimicrobial stewardship budget
so it's a win-win on these four points
so now we're going to describe for you
this three-step
process that your patient specimen takes
upon receipt at microgen
the first thing is you the provider
makes the order
you select the specimen you collect the
specimen
and then you send it off to microgen the
first thing that happens upon
entry and this is effectively at the
nine o'clock position
on the slide they isolate the nucleic
acid
the nucleic acid is then split into
three parts
the first part is submitted for 16s
ribosomal
gene uh characterization
this is a very rapid step and generally
within 24 hours of receipt
you will actually know who's there
the second piece of the nucleic acid
specimen is submitted for
next next-gen sequencing in case any of
the pcr
primers that were originally selected
for the level one
analysis failed to identify or
simply weren't present in the ngs
specimen
and finally the resistance we'll have
more to say about that
when we get to that particular point but
now i want to focus
on the 16s ribosomal
rna gene process that has been
optimized for patients specimens
and those of you who are familiar with
sexiness this is old hat
and generally a primer pair is selected
generally where you see the loops or as
i call them the cul-de-sacs
of the 16s ribosomal rna gene
this is what is subjected to genetic
drift and this is what
enables us to use the 16s
rna gene as a sentinel molecule to
identify
the microbial world again microgen is
using
specific primer pairs for the organisms
most likely to be present in your
clinical specimen
in order to identify quickly remember
this
is a diagnostic that is principally
trying to answer the question of
what is present in your patient specimen
this technology in the database has been
developed
over the last 40 years it was originally
pioneered by
carl woes and norm pace and of course
it's now ubiquitously used by
microbiologists
to characterize unknowns as well as
known
microbes so this happens to be
our urine sample then these are the
particular primers
that you are seeing this is an
evidence-based approach
based on a continuous survey on behalf
of microgen
asking the question what are the most
likely
microbes present in urine the primer
pairs that are
used to amplify up the dna target
are in the constant state of revision
and validation
and the pcr results you need to
appreciate
are dependent upon the proper primer set
being present
and tailored for your particular
specimen type
the trade-off of this is it's a very
fast technology but the downside is it's
limited by the dna concentration
which is in turn based on how well the
dna is recovered from your patient's
specimen
which is dependent upon the quality of
the dna the
quantity of dna present and
of course it's limited by primer bias
and whether or not the primer is even
present
so take for instance if you have a
fugitive microbe
one that normally isn't associated
with the target specimen like urine
if a microbial microbe that is normally
not
characterized is present uh what are you
to do
and that is where the level two comes in
so let's first look
at the level one report from our urine
specimen
this urine came from a female
patient and you can see that we have
identified from level one
two microbes pseudomonas aeruginosa
and we have a concentration estimate of
how much dna is present
about a million copies per milliliter of
patient specimen and we also have
enterococcus fecalis
which is present at a lower
concentration approximately an order of
magnitude less
again this is dependent upon the primer
set
that was used and if you recall from the
last slide
both pseudomonas originosa and
enterococcus fecalis
were primers that were present in the
cocktail that was
used to evaluate the urine sample but
oftentimes
a urine sample can actually fail pcr
and there are no bacteria present and
so you fundamentally need to ask
yourself the question
is this a case of truly sterile pieria
but don't worry your specimen was split
the nucleic acid was split at the time
of receipt
and it has been working in the next gen
sequencer effectively asking the
question
who is there so again
what could account for the negative
results again
the same limitations that we talked
about previously
requires the proper primer set the
trade-off is good it's fast but the
downside
is dna concentration the quality and
quantity of dna
and again primer bias what if
that microbe was a fugitive
so absence again is but part one of our
analysis
but again appreciate that your sample is
still in progress
with the next gen sequencing machine
and so that takes us to the level two
again your nucleic acid has been
submitted is undergoing
next-gen sequencing and let's look at
the level two report
again we see that pseudomonas and
enterococcus
were indeed identified by the next-gen
sequencing approach
but in addition we find that in this
urine specimen
we have three additional microbes
we have e coli bacteroides fragilis
and enterobacter luigi and
what you see in the rightmost column
is the percentage that that
nucleic acid represented
in the next-gen sequencing profile e
coli was in fact
the largest amount of nucleic acid
recovered and sequenced
from the ngs sample and in point of fact
e coli was the predominant organism at
about 57 percent
again the frag was 28
we see pseudomonas stilled in there but
it
only represented five percent of the
microbe
present in this particular polymicrobial
patient specimen enterococcus focalis
was in the weeds
and it didn't represent a significant
mole fraction
of the total nucleic acid present in the
next gen sequencing approach
now let's look at the negative specimen
this again is a negative urine specimen
and
while it was negative by pcr
it was not negative by the next gen
sequencing in point of fact the microbe
that was present
in our negative specimen was aerococcus
and then it was followed by some minor
players
peptimophilus and ectenegesium
and those organisms are indeed present
now again why was the pcr unable to
detect it
and more importantly why was culture
unable to detect
these microbes and again we now know
that the
nucleic acid is indeed present at a
significant fraction
in this particular patient's urine
specimen
this takes me to our third aspect of
the information that will be revealed
from the patient specimen
upon submission and that's namely
assessment of the resistone
traits present presently this is a
pcr-based approach
using an informed using a literature
informed choice on the resistance gene
screen again the resistance genes
are based on the literature
looking for which genes are going to
impact the treatment decisions made by
you
the provider and if you're not familiar
with the concept
of the antibiotic resistance i'll call
your attention to this excellent review
in nature reviews microbiology by gerald
wright
he describes in detail what the resist
dome is and it's really nothing more
than the set of genes
that the community has and in fact when
we look
at the introduction of ant widespread
introduction of antimicrobials back in
the 1930s
with the first sulfa drugs we appreciate
that the microbes have adapted
and are literally destroying the
antimicrobials in our armamentarium
and in fact as we add new antibiotics
to our formulary the microbes are of
course
adapting and in 2018 we added three
new antibiotics to the list and of
course we are continuously
looking to assess whether or not the
microbes will develop a genetic
resistance trade
in order to get around our antimicrobial
currently microgen is actually screening
for 17 genes that are clinically
relevant they are listed for us in the
middle
right of this particular slide and they
are the genes that you would anticipate
and in fact what you see at the red
arrow pointing
we again have our unculturable
unpcr-able but next-gen sequencing
result
for urine what you see is that this
particular
specimen was indeed had resistance genes
for methicillin
a broad class of beta-lactams quinolones
and bactrim so now you the clinician
need to make an informed decision at
what
is the best antimicrobial in order to
clear
this polymicrobial infection and this is
effectively what
our next-gen sequencing report looks
like
again the antimicrobials microgen
has listed for your consideration
you are the ultimate decider of what
antimicrobial to preside
prescribe for your patient and dr john
is going to go into this
in greater detail during his discussion
about how you make these informed
choices so this concludes
my portion of the talk summing up i hope
i've
introduced you to the value of the rapid
16s ribosomal rna approach to
discovering who's there but short of
that failing
at the same time your specimen is still
still being processed
through a next-gen sequencing approach
and you
actually know who's there
and finally the third piece of
information that you'll get
from your single specimen is whether or
not
the microbe is indeed resistant
or has any resistance traits present in
its genetic makeup
so that you can then make the best
informed
decision to help your patient
so dr john is going to take us to the
next
aspect of our discussion here this
morning and that's the clinical
rationale
in support of the value of coincident
culture
and next-gen sequencing and he's going
to specifically address
these three points and so without any
further ado it's my great pleasure
to introduce dr joseph f john jr
who is a member of the low country
infectious disease
practices and joe has had an even
longer and more distinguished career as
an infectious disease
practitioner than many
physicians and he is well
adept at understanding the nuances
associated with these polymicrobial
infections so dr john the microphone is
yours
thank you dr schmidt for that
introduction and thank you very much for
your excellent presentation
to give us some understanding of how
this revolutionary technology is being
used and applied let me start with my
first case of of two cases that involves
a prosthetic joint infection of an 83
year old man
living in senior housing but he plays
golf every day
and is extremely active
he had a total knee
arthroscopy 15 years prior
that resulted in a left tka and in the
last 15 years he actually had two
revisions of that
his orthopedic surgeon was then totally
unwilling to do any further surgery
unfortunately he developed new joint
swelling warmth and pain
uh with weight bearing and the synovial
tissue was in fact inflammatory
uh the surprising thing is that from a
culture and a biotrophia species
grew and at that point i received a
consultation
to give my opinion of this patient so
luckily the orthopedist was
very flexible agreed to do a second
joint aspirate
which was sent for next-gen sequencing
and i'll just briefly go into the fact
that the result of level two ngs
at microgen revealed denied by a trophy
a defect
defective which had um
had previously been described in very
few
prosthetic joint infections in fact this
was the fifth one
and in your reference list an article by
tully t-o-o-l-e-y
uh will uh amplify one of the one of the
four cases
that have been described uh in the
literature
because there's a variable antimicrobial
susceptibility with this organism
and because we had no direct
antimicrobial susceptibility
i chose to treat this patient with two
grams of iv ceftriaxone
for a multiple weeks at about three
weeks into
therapy the patient in fact
and he was taken off of the iv
antibiotics
and at that point we had to make a
mutual decision
it turned out that the patient was very
reluctant to undergo further intravenous
therapy
i wanted an iv antibiotic and he remains
right now
on oral uh clindamycin
it's very interesting i spoke to him
very recently and he's gaining strength
every day in that knee and is able to
wait there
and walk with his walker right now the
second case for consideration
is a young 26 year old lady from the
midwest with the history
of um of ear piercings uh dating to the
point of time
uh when i saw her in february of this
year
she had a right upper ear uh piercing to
put
uh another a piece of jewelry into that
and she did well for several months but
about two months after
the piercing she began to drain from the
inner penicide of that piercing
and that material was sent for a normal
culture
but only was reported back from a
commercial laboratory
as having scant normal flora
she underwent further courses of several
beta-lactam
oral antibiotics and then was referred
to me for further
consideration we immediately thought of
doing a next-gen
sequencing of this material i'd have to
be expressed slightly
and when it was done you can see the
results of the next-gen
sequencing level 2 at the right-hand
side of your screen
now i know that some of you are going to
be surprised that a few of these
organisms may not be even recognizable
to you
but i guarantee you that all of them
have been described with human
infections
i won't go into detail into all of them
although
dr schmidt has already described a a
urinary isolate
a vactinogen a challier in a urinary
tract
ngs and in fact that's one of the
organisms here
but what caught my eye in this ngs group
was uh the feingoldia magna which has
been described now
increasingly as a cause of viable but
non-culturable
organisms being itself a very fastidious
uh obligate anaerobe and so with that in
mind
we decided to treat this patient uh with
not only an oral cephalosporin
but additionally oral clindamycin and
she remains on that current therapy
right now with very slow
improvement and we can save i think for
the
q a some discussion of some of these
other organisms
uh that uh at the least are very unusual
uh when when and if cultured
so to extend a little bit of this a
second case
as i've described a lot came up well
which ones were we really going to treat
and my rule of thumb is the less likely
pathogens
you can use the literature and and
genbank to help you
make that decision uh you may even be
faced with a decision of whether to do
another ngs
on the tissue uh using it for test of
cure
of course this has to be worked out uh
in the future of how we're going to
validate
test of cure with ngs uh but it
certainly remains an option
uh for us and the the great cautionary
note here is to beware of common
anaerobic pathogens
which in fact uh may not may not grow
may not be isolated
and will be present on ngs
so so from this experience uh and
much of which been been published in the
literature
is a potential clinical utility of njs
in other
uh a chronic infections and i've i've
just listed a few here
uh for your consideration um and in this
slide you'll see
um a a a group of those that include
a chronic urinary tract infection
chronic prostatitis
chronic pneumonitis in particular the
ability to
not only isolate non-tuberculous
mycobacteria dna but also to speciate
those
prosthetic joint infections which we're
going to go into a little more detail
here culture negative endocarditis which
has already been
heralding this innovative technology and
then
some unusual situations uh particularly
bacterio bacterial uveitis and bacterial
endophthalmitis it's interesting that
this clinical utility was begun
several years ago by a wound surgeon dr
randy wolcott
and i put this last on purpose to say
chronic wound infections may be the most
widespread
use coming for ngs
both in terms of postoperative wound
infections
for a chronic ulcer infections and of
course for diabetic foot infections
the door is just opening to
understanding with ngs
the panoply of organisms responsible for
these wound infections
we've developed a little bit of a very
short clinical algorithm
uh for your consideration it's very
straightforward
and it involves the concept that you're
doing
most often with chronic infections at
the subspecialty level
and that those already uh have been sent
for
uh culture and sensitivity you can see
in the second box
and what we're willing to say to the
clinician
if you feel you have a definitive
cultural material
and want to advance the treatment this
algorithm will let you do that
and then you would decide whether you
had treatment success or treatment
failure
treatment failure would bring you down
to the yellow box suggesting that you
should move ahead
with pcr and and next-gen uh sequencing
at the same time if that culture uh
response and and culture i identify
was we want to proceed with vcr and
level 2 next gen sequencing
particularly as it's applied with
microgen
diagnostics and from that we hope
you will derive the bacterial dna and
fungal dna that is present along
with the 17 resistance genes of dr
schmidt as described
that should allow you to advance
more definitive therapy so this is kind
of a
short algorithm i'm sure it will be
expanded by
others other infectious disease and
clinical microbiologists but it gives it
gives you some hook
to try to get into how to decide whether
ngs is going to be done
whether you're doing it in your own labs
or sending it out
for uh for ngs determination
i'd like to move now to consideration of
some data
uh that we've uh collected from uh
nextgen uh and some of which will hold
a lot of surprise for you and we
consider prosthetic joint infection kind
of a synaquinone
of a catastrophic and costly infection
that raises many more questions
than simple culture and simple clinical
impression
can answer for instance what does become
the basis
of a prosthetic joint infection and
fellow co-workers at the mayo clinic
fellow id physicians
clinical microbiologists have tried to
work through a
a definitive algorithm for that what is
the interpretation of culture negative
of pji you see in the second check and
then the third
how often are pji's polymicrobial
and from the work of javed and others at
the jefferson
department of orthopedic surgery uh
we've seen now over the last four
or so years in peer review publications
that it's probable that pji's are more
often probable
polymicrobial than not which is one
reason i presented the abiotrophia case
just to outline the fact that
occasionally you will have monomicrobial
infections
albeit with unusual organisms and then
secondly
um with our large notation there how do
biofilms influence outcome
do they really matter do they alter
antimicrobial susceptibilities
and if so uh what portends as ideal
therapy
whether it be iv or oral and can we
apply
some antibiotic stewardship uh to this
particular infection and then finally
what does become the role of next
generation sequencing
in pji uh when is it done and
what are the expected results so
uh with reference to the expected
results and with the help of dr schmidt
as we looked at these organisms
we've tried to assemble for you
approximately 6 000 positive
orthopedic specimens from the microgen
database
most of these which
are you exactly from prosthetic joint
infections and what you'll see is a very
surprising
set of results uh of course these
numbers are quite large
because many specimens were taken in and
some in a
a cooperative study uh that is in in
publication now
and has been presented in abstract form
which you'll see
in your in your references headed by the
jefferson college of medicine department
of orthopedic surgery
but in this overall orthopedic look
we see a huge preponderance of
escherichia coli
uh and and cardi bacterium acnes uh
previously propriano bacterium acnes
uh that that belie what we would
most often get uh in pure culture
results uh we're all enamored of the
staphylococci and causing
uh most often these particular pji
infections but in fact
uh these data suggest that it's a much
more complicated
situation i would bring your attention
to
the fifth organism down acinetobacter
radio resistance
which was present in almost 800 of these
samples and raises the question
which i think we can discuss more in the
q a of whether
the so-called speciation in
by biochemical identification in the
clinical micro lab
is in fact accurate and
how far do we have to go beyond uh uh
dna
uh sequencing uh to raise the question
about
an organism like acinetobacter uh radio
resistance
and i will guarantee you that in this
sample
uh there were some about 220
uh asanina acetobacter balmoni eyes
so it's not that they were totally
ignored uh in this particular database
and then i would leave for your perusal
some of the other more interesting
organisms
in this panoply
the other equally important aspect of
these data are that
uh in more than one uh uh species
identification
uh 70 uh of these organisms uh uh
had more than one species of nucleic
acid
and in and in greater than two species
these accounted for fifty percent uh
of of these uh identification so that uh
these data would suggest in fact that
pji
uh and many orthopedic samples are in
fact uh polymicrobial
so to summarize some of the advantages
we see of ngs
uh in my part of the discussion uh is
that
uh in fact when we look at an infection
like pji
we note that many of these organisms are
a viable uh uh but but not culturable
uh and that uh ngs allow us allows us to
detect
minor uh and and possibly pathogenic
populations
at 24 to 72 hours um
initially for pji and then secondly i'm
sorry initially for pcr and then
secondly
uh for ngs after receipt of the specimen
and that based on a huge
greater than 40 000 library for
reference
there is good dna sequence specificity
rapid detection of antimicrobial genes
and you can see these last three
advantages at the bottom cost
antimicrobial stewardship
and in fact good reproducibility
that microgen has done with its own
validation
uh so in conclusion uh we hope you now
appreciate the limitations to
traditional microbiological cultures
uh and how many clinical specimens from
chronic infection
using next-gen sequencing can aid in
making
and help making clinical decisions this
could be at both the level of pcr
and ngs as you apply it to your decision
matrix
and then finally there's more
work that needs to be done on straight
resistance gene
uh resistosome finding in these uh in
these particular polymicrobial
infections
uh but i think we've had some experience
for instance
in a hiv resistance gene
detection for making this type of
clinical decision
the next two slides will outline just
some of the
references for ngs that we thought would
be most interesting to you and this one
highlighted
in the second slide is the abiotrophia
reference that i had referred to uh
earlier
earlier ability uh so with that i'd like
to thank you very much for listening to
both parts
of this webinar and we'd like to turn it
over now
to all of your questions and hopefully a
very fruitful discussion
thank you very much
thank you dr john and dr schmidt for
your informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
okay let's get started our first
question
is which percentage of cases regarding
resistance are explained by genophenol
interference
versus other mechanisms of resistance
which cannot be
inferred from the sequence
i'll take that question and thank you
for it that is
really a fantastic question and it's a
subject of
active research by many clinical
laboratories across the world
and in fact some of you may have seen a
really
fascinating article that appeared in
nature microbiology
entitled the rapid inference of
antibiotic resistance and susceptibility
by genomic neighbor typing and i think
that in
years to come as the number of
specimens uh processed
looking specifically for the resistome
will have a better clinical
understanding of the significance of
this
presently because this is not been done
in a structured clinical trial format
i can't give you chapter and verse
specifics
of the percentage but recognize
that the microbial community is
actively looking at this question and
it's only through clinical laboratorians
such as yourselves
who begin to use next-gen sequencing and
begin to evaluate the resistoms
present in these complex and often
polymicrobial infections
will we have an understanding to be able
to specifically address that question so
again thank you for that really
fantastic question
thank you so much for that answer okay
the next question
how critical is the total turnaround
time in diagnosing infection
how does ngs based method help or hurt
on that front
well i'll take that one for you
well it's a tough question and a good
one um
as we look closer at these ngs data we
realize that
most of the time when we see patients in
consultation we are looking at chronic
infection
of course there are very few truly acute
infections
so the real question is at what point in
time does ngs become helpful
how early could it be used and how
effective is it at changing what dr
schmidt calls the value proposition
my inclination is with clove space
infections
uh some of this has been published on a
cerebral spinal fluid
about a year and a half ago in the new
england journal of medicine uh
that there are always there are always
real surprises especially
with organisms that are viable but not
culturable
my bias is that ngs at any time
can useful as an infection drags on
for months maybe even years it becomes
extremely useful
because of viable and non-culturable
organisms particularly
fastidious microbes like the case we saw
in feingoldia magna so thanks very much
for that question
all right the next question is
how do you make decisions about
clinically relevant versus commensal
non-relevant organisms
for those detected by ngs
well of course the uh i'll i'll turn
this over to dr schmidt for his
uh input as well uh by myself quickly
saying
you can't i guess that's the short
answer and the longer answer is
that it is the very commensals
remembering also that staph aureus is a
commensal
residing in one third of the human
population in the world
in their anterior nares uh and that that
commensal
when in a place where it's unhappy uh
becomes a
a mega a mega war war machine
uh with with uh nine or more toxins
multiple
uh other virulence mechanisms so that's
a commensal organism
maybe more appropriate to the question
is the ability for coagulase negative
staphylococci
to get within clove spaces particularly
where there's hardware
and cause infections and we know that
that the behavior of that microorganism
can be so different in that closed space
uh
other than its uh its own uh niche
uh that it occupies naturally as a
commensal
so i think of these organisms as having
a dr jekyll mr hyde
ability that they sit on our skin in our
nose
even contribute to our health
in our colon but once they get into
close spaces
and into the bloodstream where they're
very unhappy they turn on alternative
mechanisms
of survival and in that deliver
virulence factors to us
that make make our uh lymphocyte and
chemokine receptors
very unhappy and turn us into a septic
or otherwise
chronic infection so that that's the
short how do you make the real decision
between
i think that's where ngs comes in very
handy for instance in our
prosthetic joint infections we often had
in 50 percent we often have three or
more
organisms often of which two were
coagulated negative staphylococci
so unfortunately species does matter of
the difference between a staph warning
a staph eye and i could go on to some of
the other 19 or so
coagulation negative staphylococci that
may infect
humans so it's a it's a it's a clinical
judgment
repeat culture and repeat ngs may be
helpful in pulling out those commensals
that have in fact now become uh
pathogens uh
uh dr schmidt would you like to say a
few things there
uh the only thing i could add to your
great explanation dr
john is we cannot divorce our thinking
from the patient's immune system
and in these polymicrobial infections
where
oftentimes they're in a biofilm
community
this is where the research and
diagnostic community
need a greater sense of collaboration
with each passing day there is a new
paper on the microbiome and how it's
signaling the host
and we have to appreciate that this
signaling and the immune consequences
of what's going on in these complex
infections
are really the the whole diagnostic
world
is at an inflection point and we really
need to
consider some of the immune consequences
that are going on
and it only will take a minor player
to effectively upset the apple cart
and dr john has alluded to that in his
explanation but i think the only thing
that
we can do is argue for a
greater sense of doing some of these
limited trials
at your facilities where you begin to
look
for infections and say the prosthetic
joint
or the shoulder or wherever they might
be
and ask the question what is actually
going on and again
by tracking outcomes we'll have a better
understanding of the significance
of the these players and again
unfortunately this is a big data issue
we need
lots of data in order to make some of
the
inferences that many of you are hoping
for
unfortunately we just don't have enough
data
from the overall microbial world in
order to appreciate
the clinical significance of it and so
again that's my plea is we have to begin
to
do this in concert with culture and the
ngs
i'll turn it back to the moderator okay
great thank you so much doctors okay
let's see next question
can assay be applied to the tissue
sections
well i'll just take that that's a
softball thank you for that
and the answer is yes um dr jeanette
pervici
at jefferson is routinely taking tissue
samples
and sending them off to microgen for
a next-gen analysis and pcr analysis
and he's getting answers back and that
was one of the three
one of the questions i raised at the
beginning when assessing
what specimen types can the laboratory
act on
and microgen happens to be able to
process
a wide variety of specimen types so you
can actually
get that answer for tissue
joe do you want to add or we'll turn it
back to the moderator for another good
question you know i would just say
that's a really exciting area be able to
take pieces of fibrotic tissue from
prosthetic joints and other prosthetic
devices a pacemaker debris
and really see organisms that you're
highly unlikely going to be able to grow
and you're very curious about that about
that dna diagnosis
okay thank you so much i have an another
question for you
um we have a mycology department that is
able to identify molds by microscopy
but we don't have any other in-house
method we routinely send out
mold isolates that we can't identify but
it commonly takes
more than a week can your ngs test be
performed directly
from the submitted iso isolate and is it
able to identify molds
the short answer is yes all you need to
do is to package up the isolate the same
way you would send it off to
a another laboratory and then
they will submit that for next-gen
sequencing literally from the isolate
that you have and microgen will be able
to determine
um the identity of the particular fungus
or if it happens to not be a pure
culture
will tell you who's there in addition to
the fungi that are present
all right i've got one more question for
you
see
does the afb panel include mycobacteria
other than
mycobacteria tuberculosis and
mycobacteria avium
the short answer to that question is
again yes
and this is go ahead joe
and i was going to say that this is a
very strong suit at microgen
and i'll do a a five second uh case
report
of a lady who's had chronic low country
south carolina has a tremendous amount
of non-tuberculosis mycobacteria a lady
presented with a long-standing history
of mycobacterium avium intercellularity
which she had quote had for years
although on culture she had only grown
it twice
on ngs of a deep sputum on her
on two occasions there was an absence of
mac
and so i think that with the sensitivity
of the uh
detecting mtm and the focus on
only uh mycobacterial cultures in in
pulling out these mycobacteria
we lose sight of the background
bronchiectasis caused by
uh the common commensals deep in the
lung uh by the time that bronchiectasis
has
has
occurred
okay thank you actually i'm going to ask
you one more question before we wrap up
if the ngs is available why at first was
it hard to identify the previous
previously called zombie virus as sars
kovi
ii why the initial reads were not able
to identify it
as close to sars in the news china was
constantly using the word unknown cause
of pneumonia
why ngs was not used to detect the
pathogen
and finding out more or i'm sorry
finding out the variation from the
related virus families
well i can't answer with the chinese
clinical laboratories were doing
but again to give china full credit
they did sequence they were able to
isolate the virus they did
publish the sequence of the virus in
literally record time
and within a month we were able to
develop diagnostic tests that
spread across the globe and they were
able to do it very quickly
if you look back in history i mean this
is
the probably the most
rapid that we've been able to identify
an offending new pathogen to the
microbial world
and the chinese do deserve a tremendous
amount of credit
in trying to characterize as you say the
zombie virus
but the fact of the matter is its
sequences weren't in the database
and unfortunately next-gen sequencing is
a reference based
technology very similar to multi-top
you're dependent upon the database
that you are using and that of course
is a limitation of this so that's why
we rely on the research community to
continue to publish
their their sequences that are
appropriately annotated
and those then are added to the database
as
warranted microgen is continuously
evaluating the literature
for new data to update its curated
database
and they are constantly revising
their algorithm that they use to process
the data
in order to get you a diagnostic
remember
this is not a research company this is a
diagnostic company
so oftentimes for our patients
especially from the patient's
perspective
time is of the essence and so you want
you as
the attending physician or the attending
microbiologist
want to be able to provide an answer
quickly
you don't want to wait months before you
get the answer
and so again it's the transition from
research
to diagnostics and diagnostics
is a very jealous um taskmaster they
they want that answer fast and so
um i can only defend my chinese
colleagues is
in that it was only a month until they
got the data
yeah uh jennifer let me pipe in there
too thanks so much
dr schmidt uh uh really for a very broad
uh an insightful look into that
i want i want to stress some of the
clinical aspects
of um of of coven 19
pulmonary infection uh with four major
points
all of which relate
to yes delineation uh for dna diagnosis
first of all we now know that there is a
microbiome
in the upper trachea and that microbiome
will highly influence
the ultimate outcome in a
uh in what is now a new not only new but
very novel
a viral infection it really took the
chinese a little
while to realize they were dealing with
uh extreme novelty uh in this infection
secondly that microbiome in the trachea
and then eventually in the lower
respiratory tract
uh in patients with altered uh with
altered lungs fibrotic lungs
um that microbiome may contribute
a co-receptor agonist
uh for instance in a recent article in
science
the contribution of uh
random carbohydrates for the attachment
of coven 19 to the ac to the ace2
receptor
so there's a lot going on in that
community
which is then joined uh by by covet 19.
uh uh thirdly the uh
and pertinent to the exactly to the
question
the real role of bacterial super
infection
in coven 19 has not been well worked out
those of you listening know the legacy
of of staphylococcal pneumococcal
and homophilus i.e haemophilus
influenzae
infection super infection uh of
post-infl post-influenza pneumonia
the analogy with covid is not
pure and not clean we just don't know
that interaction right now and the
bacterial part
of these infections has not been well
worked out
what is the relationship to ground glass
appearance so common on
uh cat scans in patients with uh with
covet 19
uh to the actual microbial contamination
of that uh pulmonary infiltrate
we have a uh we have a similar
situation in in chronic cystic fibrosis
lungs
where we have over the last 20 years
through many wonderful workers
delineated
the microbiome and what's become the
pathobiome
in cystic fibrosis and that remains to
be seen
in cova 19 but since at least
a billion a billion people will incur
a coven 19. i think this is the most
exciting question that
has been brought to the fore in many
ways this morning
because how does next-gen sequencing
as it delineates all the all the players
in the uh upper medial
and lower how does that
interplay affect clinical outcome and as
dr fauci has said
why what is it that makes some people
get better some people be totally
asymptomatic
and many people die so with that i i
thank everybody
also for their attention and turn it
back to jen
well thank you dr john and dr schmidt do
you have any final questions for or i'm
sorry any final comments for our
audience
i just want to thank them for their
attendance today and plead with them to
begin to do studies
that get published in the literature so
we can have more specific answers to
their many insightful questions
so thank you
one of our friends uh one of our friends
in clinical microbiology recently
commented about some of these cases and
how it
turns upside down the the uh academic
and clinical teaching
and clinical practice in in treating
human infection and the answer is yes
it does this is a revolutionary
uh revolutionary technology and we're
all hanging on
to try to understand how it's going to
help us and add to that value
proposition
i want to thank all the participants as
well
thank you again dr john and dr schmidt
for your time today and for your
important research we would like to also
thank lab roots and our sponsor microgen
diagnostics
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye